at the end of time
[Music]
13. o'clock
hey everybody what's going on let me see
make sure the microphone's on I always
gotta check yeah and I'm in screen yeah
you're not in the next door video not
next door over here I'm just trying to
like Escape yeah from the show yeah I
got Spock watching me
that's good you have to have Spock
watching over you at all yeah just
making sure that nobody's slipping up on
me
there you go
he has many friends and they are Vulcans
do you remember that episode yeah
all right so uh so yeah we're doing this
[__] again and uh Zach I thought you'd
be excited about this he says oh an
Autism adjacent show yeah I know we did
a show about autism a while back at your
recommendation I don't remember I kind
of feel like this particular topic
somebody recommended it like a long time
ago but I don't either that or we were
talking about something like it on
another show and I said always you
should do a show about that because this
is kind of like I guess it's sort of
autism adjacent
in the sense that it has to do with
Savant syndrome but we're talking
specifically about
um what they would call Sudden genius
syndrome or uh acquired Savant syndrome
which is somebody that wasn't born with
it which is slightly different even
though probably the mechanisms for it
are the same even though what's what
fascinates me about this kind of stuff
and I was up I was listening to a
podcast about it on the way home like in
the car and I was kind of like man if I
like I'm just fascinated by how little
we know about the human brain like they
kind of have a an idea of what roughly
like maybe is going on but
you know they're not really
not really to any great degree you know
what I mean because I kind of feel like
when we talk about this one of the main
takeaways that a lot of people are going
to have is like well can anybody tap
into this you know what I mean
because of how it comes out but
they're not quite sure like how that'll
shake out but I mean it's a possibility
I suppose according to uh
Roger pamrose and uh Stuart amaroff they
don't think the brain is generating
consciousness
that that's that's some wild [__] but
think about it
they've had people go through University
and college with normal IQ did well and
then they uh do a they have some kind of
a problem they have to go to the
hospital and they scan their brains scan
their head it turns out they got
hydrocephaly a little bitty little bitty
brain the size of a lemon
yeah you know what I mean there
shouldn't be much nothing shouldn't be
much brain there
or intelligence there
but they don't know how it works well
that works the brain is a is an
extremely plastic organ yeah in the
sense that it's very adaptable I was
watching something the other day about a
kid who was born with like literally
like a pea-sized bit of brain tissue and
they thought well this kid is never
gonna be like able to live independently
or anything like that but interestingly
because he had a mom that like worked
with him and was like really
um diligent about trying to teach him
things and stuff like that like his
brain tissue actually started to like
grow around and they showed like his
like his MRIs and like it was actually
kind of growing around the edges and
stuff because it was adapting yeah to
the new uh connections that it was
making which is like fascinating to me
yeah
I kind of think it might be
partially not something generating
Consciousness but maybe channeling it I
think it's a field of quantum particles
in superposition that give you the
sensation of being somewhere of being
and it just kind of looks through your
brain it's connected into your that's
how that's how it connects up with your
your body and uh
Roger pembrose he's that
anesthesiologist he he kind of agrees
they're not sure
but
I don't think it necessarily generates
consciousness
not in the way we would think
because uh see I've had serious head
injuries before
I'm malfunctioning and not be able you
couldn't really read too well for a few
months uh couldn't walk in a straight
line but that was still me I could see
myself doing making those mistakes
getting frustrated why can't I walk in a
straight line you know it was kind of
like uh
kind of like you're trying to look
through a lens and the lens is distorted
that's what it felt like
but there's no way to describe it
but whatever the damage was it was a
right interventricular brain hemorrhage
is what it was
and there's just bleeding and bruising
up on a
frontal lobes of brain
from a motorcycle wreck that I took in
service
and uh cost me my military career
and um I could
I was still me
you know I felt fully conscious fully
conscious but certain tasks just were
became really hard
like reading I could read
the thing is my eyes would jump to the
other sentences so I couldn't keep my
eyeballs focused on on a single line and
then when I went to scan back to the
other side of the paragraph I just read
the same line over and over and over
again it'd [__] frustrate me
and I could see myself doing it
you know but there I couldn't stop it
it's just you know most people have
never had that sensation I have it's
weird
and uh
that's what this that's what this
episode's about
some people can take a head injury in
certain cases and then they actually
they gain a new ability
now that's what I mean and it's like it
sounds kind of neat because it's like
ooze like shortcut to genius but okay
two caveats one don't go hit yourself in
the head with a hammer just to see if
you can like learn to play the piano or
whatever because that's probably not
going to work out uh this syndrome is
extremely rare
um as far as I know like I read some of
the kind of main experts in the field
and stuff like that they estimate that
there are less than a hundred in the
world that they know about probably only
about 60.
um most of the time if you get a
traumatic head injury uh it's pretty
it's it's bad
um and even some of the people in this
case where they did get like some
amazing new abilities some they it some
of them had [__] them up too like in
other ways so it's almost kind of like
is it worth the trade-off in it but if
that's what I mean well now some people
said it was like I said we'll talk about
some kind of famous cases of it
but it seems to be it has to be a very
particular kind of head injury
um it almost always had it it almost
always has to do with like the left uh
the left side of the brain the left
atmosphere like the you know the
temporal lobe I think it is or the or
the left frontal lobe it always almost
always has to do with with an injury to
that particular area and it's
interesting too because it all it almost
always manifests in a pretty narrow
range of abilities you know what I mean
it's not like you know one person gets
hit on the head and they can you know do
this one particular amazing thing and
there's like it's it kind of falls into
just like a couple of categories so that
is probably a clue as to what maybe the
mechanism for it is now once again are
they able to maintain it does it stay
yes although it's weird well the weird
thing about it and I'll get into this in
a little bit too because this is you
know I'll get into this toward the end
because this is like a little bit more
of a I don't want to say like
controversial but they don't know that
much about it yet there is they think
um something that's called because there
are essentially Savant syndrome which is
what they call it now they're
essentially three types or there's two
for sure types and then there's one
that's like a maybe type you have
congenital uh you know Savant syndrome
which is generally people with Autism or
people with um you know developmental
disorders when they're born and they're
born with this amazing ability or
whatever it is uh then you have what
we're talking about today which is
acquired Savant syndrome usually
somebody who gets an injury or an
illness of some kind that messes up part
of their brain but then that compensates
by giving them this amazing ability out
of nowhere now they've also speculated
and they think this might be the case
that there are a very rare number of
people that just spontaneously and
suddenly develop these savants without
having any particular
underlying uh injury or anything like
that at least that they can determine
again very very rare and I will say I
read a paper about it
um written by the guy who's kind of like
the main uh you know who who was
actually he's passed away a couple years
ago but he was like the main uh expert
in this in the field of savantism but um
a lot of the sample size that it was
self-reported and even though they did
seem to go through a lot of stringent
protocols and stuff like that to make
sure that they weren't just like making
[__] up
um you know I don't know if they had
like a bunch of people come in and do
MRIs on them while they were doing their
[__] or whatever and some of them
reported that it was temporary like it
came and went yeah but um but but like I
said theirs were as far as they know
we're not engendered by any kind of like
illness or any kind of underlying
physiological like an injury or anything
like that it just kind of spontaneously
happened some of them kept it some of
them not okay so we'll get into that a
little bit but usually one's engendered
by an illness or an injury will usually
stay reason why I say this is because if
an injury caused
the brain to re-root itself and access
new areas of the brain to get around the
damage and it unlocks some kind of bonus
feature okay
you would think that once that part of
the brain healed up that it would go
ahead and go back to what it would mean
go back to normal go back to normal
because I went through that process used
to be that people thought that if you
took a serious brain injury
uh that you were like a goner you were
never going to be this right no the
brain's [__] real plastic it can heal
up pretty well yeah it compensates yeah
you don't want to you don't want to
damage it because now you got to re-root
everything that could take years
depending on what it is and there's
certain areas where they can get damaged
and yeah you're probably [__] yeah
um but it's mostly happening in the
front part of the brain because you hit
something and your brain slides forward
smacks the inside of your skull and
bruises it that's usually what's
happening and combat's usually like Bomb
Blast damage because it's high explosive
and high explosive the high explosive
sets off of shock waves I get hit with a
bat
now they have you usually have a helmet
on which kind of help absorb it but
there's no telling what which way it's
going to hit if it hits you from the
back it could kill you because it's like
a blow to the back of the head that's
that's I mean that's where a lot of your
main [__] is yeah because that's like
that's autonomics that's like the older
part of your brain this up here is the
new [__] yeah all the stuff in the back
that's all the autonomic nervous system
like breathing and [__] that's all
your [__] that's all your maintenance
[__] yeah you could temporarily damage
that you just stop breathing and die
yeah now if you had a machine to keep
you breathing again maybe that might
heal but it might take [__] years but
I don't know they're using those dudes
die
so in my case
um about two years after my accident
they went ahead and the VA
gave me an IQ test again and it was the
same as it was before which is good I
was in the exceptional range
but the manifestation of it's different
if you ask me you you are different
because you've compensated from stuff
but it's still you yeah it's still you
it's just that you you're getting things
done in a different way
one of the things that I that I had was
real bad for a while was Vertigo
feelings of falling yeah I moved my head
and all of a sudden I'd start stumbling
because
the way my brain was trying to
deal with the information coming from
the inner ear I guess you know yeah like
your your kind of position my position
is space time it got a lot better as
time went on I still have it but it's
mild
and I can ride sport bikes and [__]
drag knees to corners and hang off the
side of the seats
and I'll get vertigo but it's mild and I
just I've I've compensated for it by
ignoring it you feel it but I go I don't
believe it I know it's like a phantom
it's a phantom sensation so I've just
tried to it didn't I didn't try to do it
I automatically developed the skill to
ignore my own sense of vertigo in
certain circumstances
like when you're on a bike or you're
moving real fast
and I've noticed one of the things that
that allowed me to do is if I were
playing a video game it's a flying video
game like I'm flying a jet simulator it
doesn't make a difference to me where
the Horizon is like I could be flying
the thing upside down and it it's not
affecting me I think because I don't
really have a sense of vertigo the same
way as it used to be that used to bother
me to fly you to fly a simulated
airplane upside down and go through
obstacles and [__]
so I think that was I think it was from
head injury
yeah maybe so being able to fly upside
down
Zach says isn't this what the guy they
base Rain Man off of had that guy had I
can't remember if he's still alive
actually
uh he was a year or two ago but that guy
had um a more congenital form like he
was born like that
um and that guy was a little bit I want
to say he was a little bit unusual
because he had like a lot of savant
abilities
um he was a calendrical uh calculator
which is I think one of the most common
uh things that you see Savant syndromes
like you can tell like what what day of
the week like a date like even if it's
thousands of years in the future like
you can do that
um Camp guy was saying that you can
learn to do that it's actually you
probably can because I think there's a
formula for it so if you memorize it you
could probably do it like real quick if
you practiced if you wanted to if you
wanted to like impressed people at
parties
um he could also he was also really good
at memorizing
um Maps like he could just look at a map
of a city and he could tell you the
exact distance and the exact like route
between two cities and then once you got
into the city he could tell you like
exactly where everything was like all
the streets and everything like that so
he had like Perfect Memory for distances
map making that that kind of thing but
he could do like all that kind of stuff
and that was the guy that he was uh
based on but like I said I'm pretty sure
he was born like that which like I said
is one of two forms and the interesting
thing about it is that well because the
the history of savant syndrome is kind
of interesting too I think it was first
identified at least that they know of
um and they didn't call it that but they
you know the the way they described it
was you know obvious enough that that's
what they were talking about was I think
in a German paper back in the late 1700s
and they described a guy who was um what
they would call a lightning calculator
where you know you could just give him a
math problem and he could like um you
know come up with the answer like
immediately even if it was many many
digits so they kind of talked about that
guy in the 1700s
but then it kind of became better known
in the late 1800s I believe 1887 and the
guy that talked about it he actually
gave a pretty famous I don't know it was
famous but it was like a pretty
Watershed uh lecture and his name was Dr
Langdon down uh who you might know
probably most famous for having like for
discovering or you know uh naming Down
syndrome obviously he also described at
this same lecture what they thought
might have been autism even though they
didn't he didn't call it that but the
way he actually called it uh I think
developmental retardation or something
because you could say that back then
um but what he was describing
um among his patients sounded exactly
like what you call odds I don't think
they didn't name it autism I don't think
it's of the 40s but he was clearly uh
naming that but he actually talked about
uh Savant syndrome as well and that's
kind of where it came from now obviously
back then in the 1800s
um they still called people that had
this condition whether you were born
with it or whether you acquired it later
on
um an idiot savant which you know like I
said not a real PC term and the stupid
thing though about it was that even in
even when it was okay like even when it
was like clinically correct like to call
someone an idiot like that was an actual
scientific term even by those standards
it still wasn't accurate because they
said well back in the day when you they
used idiot for you know to mean like a
person with a low IQ it usually met
somebody with an IQ of 25 or lower that
was that was the standard definition
whereas most people with Savant syndrome
had IQs of 40 and higher like you know
the vast majority of them so it wasn't
even accurate by their own standards so
obviously they called it idiot savant
for a while and then for a while too
like off and on they would call it
autistic Savant but that is also not
accurate because only about 50 of the
people with Savant syndrome are actually
on the autism spectrum the other people
have other either other congenital
developmental disorders or were injured
or had some kind of brain illness that
caused it to happen later on so now they
just call it Savant syndrome just kind
of as a catch-all so you know so that's
like the more accurate and also doesn't
sound mean like like idiots
but like I guess it doesn't sound mean
to them back then but so um let's talk
about Zack says I remember falling down
the stairs a couple times as a kid and I
can only imagine what that affected yeah
um
murder hornets and I got struck by
lightning in my penis grew 12 inches
that count yeah sure
[Laughter]
James Knapp said the formula is real
easy actually I'm assuming you mean for
like the the calendar one net and yeah
and I will say that there is I don't
know how large a contingent this is but
there is like a set of scientists
neuroscientists and stuff like that that
don't actually believe that Savant
syndrome is real necessarily
um at least to the extent that some
people because one like I said it is
very rare um even by the most generous
estimate there are less than 100 uh that
they know of in the world
um you know there might be lots that
they don't know about I'm just saying
that's the one that are ones that are
known in the scientific literature now
on the Paranormal side because we'd
become a paranormal on this channel too
um I read a book called psychic Warrior
and I don't remember who the guy's name
who wrote it it was a long time ago but
this actually was verified Congress did
do all this the US Army had a special
group of Psychics
that were uh they were using them as
remote viewers
this particular guy I think he was in
the 75th infantry as an Army Ranger and
got shot in the head with an M16 but he
the bullet hit his K-pop while he was at
the range
and I think it was just an accidental
discharge somebody shot him in the head
they hit the K-pop so the Bullet never
went into a skull but the
the
um the concussion was strong enough to
knock him out he was on
profile for a while
they got a clean bill of health once he
recovered sent him back to his unit
and he kept dreaming true he'd have
these dreams that would come true
and he told his Co about it the CEO said
the next time you have one of these
dreams you think it's gonna come true
you tell me
so he told him he says yeah I had this
dream and I forgot I forgot exactly what
it was and I said I have a dream this is
going to happen and see I was like okay
let's see if it happens a few days later
it did happen that CEO reported that guy
to
somewhere in mi military intelligence
and they sent him to that unit
it was supposedly I think that's where
they they may have made the movie the
minister goats that might be that same
unit I'm not sure
but so this is a that's a case where a
guy evidently uh
acquired the ability to somehow dream
things that would actually happen
which maybe you could do that
but not it's paranormal but maybe it
wasn't
um
you know mystical
maybe your brain is such a good quantum
computer that it can estimate what would
happen based on probabilities and it
would go this is what's going to happen
that's I'm that's what I'm imagining
that's still good enough well no that's
what I'm saying it's like for all
intents and purposes that would still be
like ability yeah and the thing about it
is that and I think we I kind of teased
this like when we were talking on The
Haunting show when I was talking about
um the this topic the interesting thing
about this is that I kind of feel like
maybe people have the perception that
you know sudden genius syndrome or like
acquired Savant syndrome it's like oh
you know you Bonk your head on a wall
and then all of a sudden you are a
musical genius or something like that
and that's not quite the way it works
but I feel like people maybe perceive
it's like oh it triggers something in
your brain which
is not entirely accurate it's almost
kind of like
the part of your brain that's damaged
is like the inhibitor and like when the
inhibitor is damaged it lets other parts
of your brain flourish yeah which is
what LSD does that's right and actually
I was watching a TED Talk by the guy
that I was talking about is kind of like
the main uh you know that was done
before he died and um he said the same
thing he said you know LSD or he's like
to you know to a lesser extent
methamphetamine
um that does a similar thing to your
brain where it's basically kind of like
suppressing inhibitor neurons like in
her yeah so so it's allowing other parts
of your brain to like kind of like go
crazy and like do [__] that they
wouldn't normally be doing yeah and you
you experience this effect as your
Consciousness happening in a larger area
now right in other words mind expansion
or Consciousness expansion be like
you're watching this on a single screen
and it's this big what would happen if
you the screen is now six times larger
and there's more data in the other part
because it's just lighting up bigger
right a bunch of stuff at once right and
and weird shit's happening and it's in
the other parts of the screen it's
that's showing you data of what you may
be seeing soon based on how you feel you
may be going over to this part of the
internet and over here other stuff's
happening and this is what you think is
happening over here
um mind altering drugs or mind expansion
drugs are
interesting CIA is very interested in
them they use them for a bunch of
different things
white people's memories out brainwashing
it's called trauma-based Mind Control
they use it for that
they wanted to use it as a weapon
because it has no overdose points so you
could spray it out of a crop duster on
troops and get them to trip out
um and without killing them
or you can also use it to like voyages
inward into the Consciousness possibly
unlocking things like Visions that's
what Native Americans do that all the
time me and my buddies used to do it if
I can get it it's hard to say you know
what I mean
some of the stuff that we would Envision
did come true
but could it just have been intuition
because your brain is so good at
estimating them what may happen because
your brain's doing a bunch of [__] doing
bunch of scenes that you're not
conscious of at all times that's why I
was listening to a podcast about this
earlier and I like that this guy said
this because I feel like a lot of people
still believe that myth that like oh you
only use 10 of your brain you have so
much more potential no you use your
whole entire brain most of the time it's
just like different parts of it for
different things and a lot of this stuff
that it's doing is not conscious
but you still have to have it going on
in the background you don't really
realize how much how hard your brain has
to work in order for your perception of
the world to be as relatively normal as
it is Stuart hammeroff believes and he's
got decent evidence having to do with
microtubules in the brain that
there's Quantum processes going on in
there it's not digital it's analog and
it's Quantum and then it's not all just
happening in the brain some of it's
happening outside the brain and a cloud
of quantum particles that are entangled
through quantum entanglement and they're
also in superposition and also slightly
outside normal space time
it's wild so in other words you got a
Quantum Soul that's somehow emanating
from the brain and then they surmise and
Roger Pembroke also says that it's
possible that once those particles are
entangled you could take the brain away
and they would stay there entangled so
you would have a soul that would survive
death
that's the
they're theorizing that and it may be
possible and it kind of lines up with
certain things that happen to me the
out-of-body experiences now you take
that Quantum field and
teleported away from the body and now
it's your mind is you're seeing things
from somewhere else now and people see
you that kind of stuff
wild Consciousness is a lot more
complicated
than we know
what I was going to say before was that
there is still a little bit of
controversy over whether acquired Savant
syndrome or even Savant syndrome in
um you know uh people on the autism
spectrum disorder and you know maybe
contrary to popular belief not everybody
who has autism spectrum disorder has
these Savant things they estimate that
it's only about 10 of people with um
autistic
like that are on the autism spectrum
have these kind of savant abilities
um but like you said like like James
Knapp was pointing out with um I believe
the most common uh Savant ability that
you see in these cases is uh being a
calendrical calculator like I said being
able to like guess dates and stuff but
the thing about that is as I mentioned
it's just a mathematical formula and if
you were able to memorize that and could
do it like really quickly like I said if
you were really into it and want to do
it like a magic trick then um then you
could do that and maybe you could kind
of fool people into thinking that you
were some kind of savant so because it's
so rare there is a small contingent of
scientists that think that maybe it
doesn't even exist but I don't know
about that because they have actually
been able to to at least a a lesser
degree and a temporary degree they have
been able to replicate it in quote
unquote neurotypical
people
um by electrically stimulating certain
parts of the brain like it'll make you
like Savant like for a brief period of
time like you know what I mean like
they'll they'll come in they'll put the
cap on you they target this one
particular area your brain and then they
give you a test or they give you
something like that and you do like [__]
hot at it but then you know a couple
hours later it just like Fades away well
it'd be awesome if you could implant
electrodes in there see that's kind of
what I'm I don't even know this
that's like one of the things that I
because I I don't know I was listening
to podcasts but earlier and they said
that you know that'd be cool but it'd be
really scary I'm like no it wouldn't
that be [__] awesome you'd have to
have everything mapped out just right
it'd be the same as any any other
performance enhancing drug or whatever
it's just that this would be
electromagnetic stuff I mean yeah
there'd be a risk but there's a risk
there's a risk everything pretty much
Danny's asking would the main character
Johnny from the dead zone be considered
uh one of the uh uh uh Savant like this
maybe not like this but he'd be a savant
like what I was talking about like the
psychic savant
he he
can a coma wouldn't he yeah yeah so head
injury from an automobile accident well
as I said I think that some people
even though obviously it's hard to
quantify paranormal abilities or psychic
abilities or something like that but
some people have reported that but
usually
um when they talk in the scientific
literature when they're talking about
Savant syndrome they're usually talking
about something that can be Quantified
or something that can be measured
um you know such as people that can you
know suddenly play the piano and they
didn't know how or something like that
you know what I mean Johnny from the
dead zone if you saw that happen and if
you were if it was happening to you you
would probably interpret interpret it as
something definitely paranormal maybe
something Supernatural
but you could also look as a no maybe
what it does is a certain areas in his
brain were so good that they could
just by coming in contact with a person
know that they were a serial killer or
that they were a tyrant rise into power
just through something that a quantum
computer could do just endless
combinations and computations and
estimations of how
how future events will go and I would
think that a person could probably
estimate that
yeah I mean someone who was very very
observant and had like a lot of um you
know interconnection in their gray
matter and then there's a bunch of
cervantism happening in weird spots and
inhibitions are gone because the
inhibitor neurons aren't fire and and
all of a sudden he might get a vision of
the future and that Vision might be real
accurate
not totally accurate but might be very
I could I could
I could imagine that because I can
imagine a quantum computer being able to
do that
well the thing about this particular I
think the thing that fascinates people
so much about particularly acquired
Savant syndrome is that
you know because you hear these stories
of like somebody getting a head injury
and then all of a sudden being like a
sudden genius at something and then
you're that leads to the next logical
question which is well does everybody
have these amazing abilities like you
know is everybody a mathematical genius
is everybody a musical genius and all it
takes is like a little bit of
farting around in your brain and like
all of a sudden we can all do it I would
say not everybody probably not because
everyone's different yeah and some
people like you said that one guy had a
brain the size of a pee so there's not
not as much to work with yeah
um
let's just say that
you would think that your average person
could probably do it
yeah yeah with modification because that
knowledge had to come from somewhere it
had to be in your brain someplace and
I'm assuming that if it's in the you
know that person's brain that's just
like an average person that it's
probably in most people's brains but the
thing about it is that because the
abilities that are unlocked if you want
to use that word they usually fall like
I said in a very narrow spectrum of
abilities and pretty much all of them
have to do with memory like prodigious
memory uh you know mathematical musical
something like that it's usually
something like that yeah you know what I
mean so it it's which just says to me
that your brain is maybe seeing things
in a particular way in a mathematical
way and we'll get into that because one
of the cases that I want to talk about
uh kind of illustrates this point pretty
good but your brain is seeing things a
particular way but then you have other
layers on top of that brain that are
kind of covering that up to make
everything look like reality quote
unquote you know what I mean so when you
have a construct happening in your mind
right right right yeah well it's because
well it's it's kind of just um it's it's
because
it's kind of like in service of how our
eyes see things yeah and like we have to
you know our brain has to be constantly
like constructing what I'm not saying
that it's like oh the you know the
world's a matrix or anything like that
but it's just like you know it our eyes
are not perfect our brains are not
perfect we're very kind of clutched
together and we have to get as accurate
a portrayal of reality as possible you
know just for survival purposes so your
brain is constantly trying to like take
in all this information and putting it
into a framework that you can comprehend
you know what I mean that's as accurate
as it can make yeah and it does that by
leaving a lot of [__] out it does like
the UV Spectrum isn't in there [__]
heat is IR isn't in there there's a lot
of stuff missing from your sensories
your sensory well you know that you're
you don't need them to catch animals you
know what I mean for we don't need them
but then you have other stuff like bats
that could with [__] sonar and echo
location they can probably use
echolocation as well as we can see
Vision I bet you they can see shapes and
everything
well I was watching a documentary about
a guy who um who was blind and he taught
himself echolocation yeah and he's
really good at it he could see
something's uh
shape the difference between a ball and
a square yep and that's good yeah
they've tested him out and I don't think
he was born blind either I think he went
blind later but he just like taught
himself to do it yeah so he just like
goes around and like he you know he's
riding his bicycle he's just clicking
yeah and he knows where everything is
yeah and I'm like that's crazy like
Daredevil yeah yeah but but I mean when
it's amazing but then like when you hear
about it's like well you know of course
a bat can do it yeah so it's like if a
human if you really wanted to do it then
yeah you'd be able to do it yeah because
you're forced to do it right so I kind
of feel like there's a lot of abilities
that
you know while obviously it wouldn't
come naturally if he really really
wanted to do it and really applied
yourself to doing it yeah you'd be able
to learn it yeah like some out of Dune
with the damn special training camps
yeah you'd be able to do that in the uh
that's cool though and then you then
your worlds are getting into like
transhumanism and being a cyborg
where you can implant
electrodes and implants into certain
parts of your brain and then access them
through a
through a phone or cell phone and
fine-tune your brain for certain tasks
like I'm gonna paint something so I'm
gonna shut this down and turn this on
and I'll be able to paint like [__]
crazy
it'll be beautiful you know what I mean
or write music or that'd be awesome do
you think you know what I do that you
know what's interesting yeah so would I
yeah in a heartbeat well you know it's
interesting
um too is that one thing they've started
to notice like they have you know the
the research into Savant syndrome is not
you know it's still kind of Fairly
Cutting Edge there's not a lot of people
working on it but they said one thing
they had started to to uh notice
was that not only people with head
injuries and people with Autism Spectrum
disorders and things like that but they
said they've also started to notice it
in
um elderly people with certain types of
dementia
um you know they obviously are losing a
lot of their uh you know frontal over
they're losing a lot of their kind of uh
you know
sort of higher functioning yeah uh but
they said a lot of them not maybe not a
lot but the ones they've heard about
have discovered new like creative
talents like are to like they've become
like artistic prodigies and things like
that because like I said you know it's
obviously not good because their brain's
degenerating they can't remember [__]
anymore and stuff like that and they
can't remember their families but
they're in turn like developing these
really like hot these you know amazing
artistic abilities I guess because the
certain parts of the brain that were
maybe suppressing that before or
something like that like other parts of
their brain are like coming in to take
it take up the slack or whatever
um let me see dudes I just saw something
that I wanted to uh Camp guy said they
say that Mozart wrote down most of his
music no perfect no Corrections it was
like he was channeling the music and
just transcribing it I had heard that as
well I read a couple of um biographies
of Mozart and one that I read that was
kind of
um written by you know one of the
world's you know best Mozart experts or
something like that said that's
partially true but they said it's kind
of an exaggeration they said they do
have some of Mozart's like original
written music that did have like some
minor corrections but nothing like you
would see did you make Corrections just
writing sentences down if you're writing
a book it could be friends sentences
yeah corrections I mean
yeah you know I mean just because he
makes a correction that doesn't mean
dude wasn't awesome yeah I mean he was
yeah he was I mean clearly he was a an
amazing Prodigy like he was but the
thing about it was that
what a lot of people don't yes he was
super talented yes he was a crazy genius
and everything like that but I think a
lot of people forget that one his dad
was also a composer and his dad started
him out when he was very young him and
his sister yeah he was doing that before
his Consciousness even developed you
just started doing that yeah so it's
just so it's kind of like he not only
had it wasn't just like it came out of
The Ether it came out of nowhere he was
uh he had the ability and that it was
honed and trained like from a very very
very young age so that's why when people
say he was writing like operas that ate
and stuff like that I'm like well he
started from [__] birth pretty much
it's just like
it's just like other things uh
okay like for instance if you have a
person like Mozart who's writing and
composing music basically from birth
it's not quite the same skill as a
person who's learned it it's it's
different very different good example
would be
uh little kids that learn how to shoot
when they're little kids all right they
can shoot well forever after that
because they're just they keep they
don't they don't think about it they
don't have to think about it
shooting scales in a person that learns
it later on and towards you know the
young adulthood it's a perishable skill
for them it's not as perishable for
somebody just grew up doing that same
thing with riding horses and stuff I can
jump on a horse
it could be it could be off of it for
years and it's just normal I don't even
think about it well it's the same thing
that you see with children that are
raised in bilingual houses they don't
think about
um they don't think about switching
languages back and forth because they've
always done it and that's all they've
ever known if you learn a language later
on in life you really have to like
maintain it and like keep up with it or
you'll forget about it
um you know like yeah I took French for
four or five six years uh and I got
really good at it but it's like I don't
use it anymore so I don't remember that
much of it you know what I'm saying some
of the great Shooters in the past like
Wild Bill Wild Bill Hickok he didn't
even use sights he just knew where every
pistol would hit you could just sit up
just snap shoot and shoot hold pistols
straight out to the sides and shoot
targets and hit them simultaneously
without looking at them excellent
spatial awareness like dudes that can
throw a basket it's it's like that it's
the same skill basically
same part of the brain doing that
Camp guy said they say that even
swimming is very hard to learn after one
becomes a non-swimming adult yeah I've
I've heard that that's the case I'd like
I don't know personally because I
learned to swim and I was very very
young yeah I don't even remember
learning to swim I don't either yeah
um because I mean I grew up in Florida
like everybody has pools the ocean and
everything like that so it's just kind
of like we were always around water and
so I don't remember learning to swim I
just always did I'm sure I did but I
don't really remember traditional
Southern families make sure their kids
[__] can swim damn near at Birth
because all the water that we're around
you know I mean it's a good idea if they
don't know it's a good idea to like
teach and honestly like you know I had a
friend that had a kid and she had that
baby in swimming classes like a series
she was old enough to it's it's a good
idea just so just so you know in case
they fall into a pool or something they
don't [__] Panic you know they know
how to swim
I would advise it especially if you live
around here but you know
um
let's see Zach says I always notice when
the cuts and movies feel wrong during
scenes and I'm always correcting in my
head how I would do that if that was my
job yeah so you have like you're like an
editing stuff
but yeah so um what I was gonna say
something to you about um yeah not
remembering learning how to swim you
know what's weird I don't remember
learning how to read either me neither
I just knew how am I and my well my
family told me that I started reading
really early yeah they said you could
read when you were about two yeah I
could read before I went to kindergarten
yeah I could too well I didn't go to
kindergarten I just started in first
grade you didn't have to go to
kindergarten when I was a little I was
reading Dr Seuss and [__] oh I was
reading like Encyclopedia Britannica
[Laughter]
Dr Seuss and uh Bible stories I used to
read to my to my cousins my older
cousins who couldn't read yet
Encyclopedia Britannica before you were
in kindergarten yeah oh man this [__]
very
it's great yeah
she I could I can attest that yeah she's
all cerebral and [__] I'm all cerebral
yeah yeah it's okay I'm working on my
body connection with it though we're
gonna make I'm making her physical she's
gonna be physical
got her in training whatever it's all
goes inward all her all her neuro neural
connections all go all connect somewhere
else inside the brain
you know what does that mean you're not
very coordinated well I know that's
though you can dance but yeah but you're
you're not very I think the reason
I I think about this a lot because I've
always been very klutzy like throughout
my life like as far as like I can't walk
without like running into a [__] wall
but it's like I can but I can dance
really good yeah I think like I'm really
like coordinated I'm impressed I don't
understand it but I guess because when
I'm dancing I'm not thinking about it
that's why I overthink my I overthink
most of her connections just connect
back inside the brain it doesn't connect
to the to the body it's very self-rex
it's just going inside itself yeah I
don't know where the ideas come from I
don't even know well and the thing is
it's like I don't mind being like that
it's frustrating because I try to do
like a simple thing like just with my
hands and I'm just like why don't my
[__] hands work it's like they don't
can't hold a tool like I can't hold like
I drop [__] and I'm just like I don't
know where my [__] is in space and stuff
like that it is frustrating it just
wasn't learned but
um but on the other hand it's like I
don't mind being mostly like if I could
just be a brain in a jar that would be
awesome I I would like that
hahaha
I know it's a weird thing to say
one was just [__] strange man that's
okay I'll take that I'm into the Greco
Roma view of mankind and being [__]
spiritual intellectual and physical you
know what I mean where you're balancing
good and evil together and you're using
them appropriately you know that's
that's that's you know that's the way I
look at things well that's all well and
good Jen's all inside her mind yeah like
I said I'm like a Creator I'm like a
brand new brain Creator yeah
and that's okay that's just that's just
that's what you do that's that's what
you're just that's my thing that's my
thing yeah
Zach says I mean an Autism thing is poor
spatial awareness I'm a huge Klutz too
sometimes lose my balance when I'm just
standing can never ride bike either I
can ride a bike um I did learn to ride a
bike but um yeah I've had that where
I've just been standing there it's
looking and I just like tripping all
over and like now we have a house with
stairs I'm very very I like have to do
each stair at the same time because I
get really
dizzy and like if you're gonna run into
the wall and [__] like that so you know
but that's just it's like I said it's
frustrating but what are you gonna do uh
Jeffy art said I remember being able to
read independently when I was five it
was like a switch suddenly went off in
my head before that I needed assistance
yeah and that's kind of like
um some of the people that reported
Sudden Savant syndrome meaning like they
didn't even have an injury or anything
some of them reported no particular
reason but then all of a sudden they
just like a light went on and they just
understood something like they
understood like the underlying
principles
um which like I said is interesting and
kind of opens up the possibility that
everyone can do it if they
want it bad enough or it could be like
we talk about when we talk about
Poltergeist activity that maybe you have
to like not think about it like you have
to allow it yeah rather than like want
it consciously yeah which is hard to do
and and you have to you have to believe
it to be an outside agent doing it not
from within
because it's not you it's another you
Zach says maybe it's the same reason I
can't drive yeah I didn't learn to drive
until I was in my 20s
but my dad tried to teach me when I was
a teenager and he gave up but uh I did
but I did learn later on like I paid and
took classes
[Laughter]
uh but yeah so let's talk about a few
cases of are you laughing at me no okay
yeah you are I seem like smirking back
there let's talk about a few kind of
famous cases of people that had um all
right
that have had um well I'll wait till you
get back because you probably want to
hear these or unless you don't care oh
now that you've not
yet I gotta you know what I mean
and Zach I have to tell you that even
though I you know I can drive now and um
you know and I have been driving for
many many years and actually now I drive
a lot obviously because I have to drive
like two hours every day but I'm still
um
and I'm trying to be less like this but
I'm still like real like overthinky and
like Panic stricken which is probably
not good you know like if
so like if if something bad happens on
the road I'll be just like I won't even
know what to do because I'll just like
freak out probably but I try to like
consciously not be like that because I
know that I'm like that also I have zero
patience
for other people being on the road and
in fact I would be super happy if I
could drive and nobody else was on the
road ever that would be really awesome
like the second one other person's on
the right I'm like oh [__] here's this
[__] what are they gonna do he had
already made and then I start freaking
out I don't like it but you know what I
mean that's why I was like so happy when
I was like working at home all the time
now that I have to drive everything it's
like stressing me out
but because I don't
I don't like being around other people
they do stupid [__]
they do stupid [__] and it makes me
nervous
all right
so let's talk about some of these
interesting because I always thought
these were like really really
interesting cases
so um as I said acquired Savant syndrome
a particular world it's actually Savant
syndrome in general whether it's
congenital or acquired is uh very very
rare as I mentioned earlier
so you know there's not really a lot of
case studies to pull from
um I will recommend uh I'm sure most of
you have probably heard of Oliver Sacks
very very famous uh neuroscientist they
made a bunch he's written a [__] ton of
books uh they've made some movies based
on his cases and things like that but he
wrote one in particular that was called
music Ophelia and a couple of the guys
that I'm going to talk about were in
there and I read it a couple years ago
and it's really good like all of his
books are good like I've read most of
them but that one was like really good
because I'm interested in music and so I
was interested in all this kind of like
it was sort of about people that it got
these musical abilities like suddenly
okay so this guy here that we're going
to talk about
his name is Alonso Clemens now this is
one of the cases where
uh
I'm not really sure that the ability
that he got I mean I'm not saying it's
not amazing it is but he paid a terrible
drastic price for it some of the other
people like you know were able to mostly
go back to normal functioning sort of
and some of them even came to view their
new abilities as you know a gift or
whatever and this guy kind of thought
that too but he was pretty [__] up so
uh just take that under advisement like
I said if you're trying to like do this
to yourself don't don't hit yourself in
the head with a hammer trying to get
like special superhero abilities so
Alonzo Clemens
now uh he was born in 1958 in Boulder
Colorado now when he was about three or
four years old uh he fell which was a
really bad uh accident like he basically
like fell on his head and like got a
terrible head injury
now this injury was very severe
um it ended up because he had been uh
you know normal before that but
afterwards um it left him with an IQ of
40. and uh he never progressed past uh
like the mental capacity of a
six-year-old
um so basically after it happened
they're like well
um the kid is never gonna be able to
live independently um he's always gonna
have to have somebody but I mean to a
large extent he did kind of grow up and
you know he needs help still but he was
able to have he has a little apartment
next to his mom and like she kind of
looks after him and stuff but he was in
the Special Olympics he does power
Olympic power lifting
um you know and he has a part-time job
and everything like that so he has been
able to kind of like adapt but
interestingly they said not too long
after the accident
he suddenly all he wanted to do was
sculpt stuff
um and if he couldn't get his hands and
usually clay like if he would give him
like you know Clay or Plato or whatever
and he would start sculpting with it he
couldn't get that he would just go and
get in the butter or get whatever the
[__] he could get it was just became
like a compulsion which is something
that you see a lot in these uh acquired
Savant things it's like they they said
they suddenly felt like like an
obsessive need to like do this [__]
suddenly even though they didn't give a
[__] about it before possibly
so this guy starts sculpting things
what he sculpted was animals he always
sculpted animals and interestingly he
could always sculpt them
completely
photo realistically even if he only saw
them for like a second like if you
showed him a picture of a gorilla like
for a second he would make a completely
accurate three-dimensional sculpture of
a gorilla that looked exactly like that
[__] picture wow
um and he just be like I said he started
doing that now interestingly they think
what's going on because like I said he
has other uh severe developmental uh
difficulties obviously like caused by
the accident like I said he had been
neurotypical prior to that as a child
but
um what the thing about it is that they
think what's going on and we'll get into
this a little bit when we talk about
like a different another guy who had a
similar thing happen but they think what
might be happening is that you know how
I said that your brain
the way that your eyes work it's almost
kind of like taking pictures all the
time like click click click click like
that and like your brain is kind of like
smoothing it out for you
they think maybe the part that Smooths
out the [__] doesn't work anymore and
that this dude is able to
freeze frame a moment and hold it yeah
in his brain and just like look at it
like it like it was still there yeah you
know what I mean I could picture that
right and so that they think that they
maybe that's what's going on because
they're like the detail that he puts
because I've seen some of his sculptures
and they're incredible yeah like you
couldn't do that by thinking about it no
no that's something you just have to
allow happen yeah you just get a feeling
for how it looked the feeling is so
intense that yeah you remember how it
looked
yeah I mean down to like the smallest
detail and it's completely yeah and it's
completely um anatomically correct it's
completely accurate he's remembered even
the Gestalt of how it feels to see it
yeah and he's pretty much and he he's
he's replicating the Gestalt of what
what you feel like and what you feel
when you see this thing that's what he's
doing yeah yeah and it's it's funny
because like I said he has like a lot of
other difficulties like stemming from
the accident but you know so they asked
him sometimes because he kind of was
operating in obscurity for a while until
like people kind of got interested in
Savant syndrome like after rain man came
out and after Oliver sacks's books and
stuff like that but um so he didn't
really come into the public
Consciousness I feel like until the 80s
but they started asking him like how do
you do it like what do you see but he
doesn't really I mean he can't really
explain it which I guess you wouldn't be
able to no he basically just points at
his brain and is just like yeah I did
yeah
maybe he I mean he probably if the [__]
happened to him when he was so young
that he probably doesn't know any
different so he maybe he doesn't
understand the question he's just kind
of like well easy he's probably it's
easy to him that's what I mean obviously
and the thing about it is that like a
lot of his smaller sculptures
because a lot of times he'll do them in
clay and then later you know some like
his assistant will have them like you
know cast them in bronze and stuff
um and he's done like all kind of
animals like bulls and horses and you
know all everything and they said that
he they started taking him to the Denver
Zoo so he could like see the animals so
he could like do like you know expand
his repertoire or whatever and he seemed
to really like enjoy that but they said
most of his sculptures are you know
fairly small and he does them in like an
hour which is again amazing
um can he sell him oh yeah yeah uh he
did start selling them yeah but if they
said he has done some life-sized ones
too
um but yeah they said by the time 1987
rolled around he just was they said he
would just did it all the time and like
they built him a little Studio he has
like a little apartment or whatever like
next to his mom's house and like by the
80s he had already done like 500
sculptures and like his whole apartment
and then um they he started kind of
coming to the attention like I said once
uh you know Rayman came out and people
started becoming more aware of savant
syndrome so you know knowledge about him
kind of like filtered into the public
Consciousness and so kind of galleries
Came Calling was like oh my God this
dude's amazing and like I said his
sculptures are really beautiful
and he basically
um they actually the one one life-size
one that he did which was horses uh it's
called three follicing frolicking foals
that was a tongue twister
um that sold for forty five thousand
dollars dang actually and a lot of his
stuff sell like his smaller stuff sells
for about a thousand dollars stuff like
that but he's had like Gallery shows and
everything like that like he's doing
with the world yeah and it's just and
he's been on TV and all kinds of other
stuff and like I said he's he lives a
pretty quiet life like I said he's you
know did you sign him oh I don't know I
didn't notice
but yeah but I've seen some like I said
just look up um you know Alonzo Clemens
and look at some of his sculptures
they're really really nice and like I
said they're
the one that I saw I saw one of the bull
I saw the um the frolicking foals one
like of the horses that was also like
amazing but yeah they look
real I mean they look real which is
crazy like I said I think he starts him
out in clay but then like he they cast
him in bronze or whatever you know what
I mean but yeah he's been on a bunch of
documentaries and you know books and
stuff like that but like I said he's not
really able to articulate
um
how he does it because you know to us it
seems like amazing but like like I said
to him it's probably just like man
whatever it's just like [__] Monday
morning he doesn't know because that's
the way he's always yeah seen in the
world I mean he was so young when it
happened to him that he probably doesn't
remember anything prior to that
other guy whose name was uh Anthony or
Tony chakoria
and this guy he's actually an orthopedic
surgeon
he started out as
and interestingly this guy was uh was
featured in the Oliver Sacks book that I
just mentioned called music philia
um and so this happened in 1994.
so Tony chicoria was 42 years old at
that time and was living in Albany New
York
and he was using a pay phone because it
was 1994. nobody had cell phones yet
and he had just hung up the phone and it
just like left the booth and was like
kind of standing there and he got struck
by lightning I remember this in the head
yeah
um it went in his head and came out his
left foot it was like he's like you burn
and he actually kind of died for for a
minute like it stopped his heart lucky
for him uh the woman that was waiting to
use the pay phone after him was a nurse
so she was actually able to resuscitate
him until like the ambulance got there
and stuff like that
um but he had an out of Body Experience
uh he said that he
he didn't remember what it felt like he
just said he heard a you know a bang and
then he saw his body laying on the
sidewalk like surrounded by like a blue
white light that's what he said he saw
um but yeah so his heart had stopped
but the nurse revived him and uh you
know and he was okay like he made like a
recovery
now
he seemed like he was doing all right
but a few weeks after he got struck by
lightning
he started having memory problems and he
kind of said he felt um he just didn't
feel right he felt like very sluggish
and logy or whatever
and so he went to a neurologist because
like you know he's a doctor too so he
knew that like something was probably
wrong
so
um the neurologist does an exam
like an EEG and they didn't see anything
weird on the EEG
and so they're like well we don't see
anything so you know maybe it's just you
know recovery or whatever and then a few
weeks after that he said Well he kind of
felt normal again like you know he's you
know he felt energetic he's like I teach
felt totally fine
and uh also his memory improved and so
he's like okay well that was an ordeal
and that's over
but then
over the next couple of days like after
he went back to normal
he started again with this obsessive
feeling he's like I really really want
to listen to classical music classical
piano music but she had never given a
[__] about before
um so he started listening to it and
listening got like obsessive about it
then he's like I need to buy a piano so
anyone out he bought a piano
and he said that everything in his head
it's just all it was just his head was
filled with music all the time and he
just had to get it out you know what I
mean so it's like that's why he had to
buy the piece that's that's another
thing like why you know when they say
like uh one of the Hallmarks of savant
syndrome is this obsessive need to like
there's all this information in there
and I have to get it out somehow so
that's what he was doing so we bought a
piano
and he just started uh playing and
basically within a couple of months
after getting struck by lightning
um he basically just like played piano
composed all the time and ended up doing
uh he debuted his first composition in
2007.
now he did say that he kind of taught
himself to play but I mean it was only
like a couple of months
so obviously this ability just kind of
sort of came out of nowhere because you
know obviously people that play at the
at the level that he plays would usually
like train for years and years but he
did actually go to like a kind of a
piano learning camp or whatever
um and has given uh you know concerts
and things like that and he's learned to
play like all these really complex
pieces and he started composing his own
stuff uh obviously he wrote one called
the lightning Sonata which I thought was
very funny
um but yeah
so he's also apparently he's working on
a book but I don't know if that's come
out yet or not but yeah he was one and
like I said one of the very common
things the calendar thing is the most
common like with this Savant kind of
thing but uh musical ability is probably
the second most common and they said you
know what's really interesting is that
musical ability particularly piano not
always guitar is kind of in there too
but it's almost always piano or
classical music
um that is a very very common thing and
congenitally it usually goes along with
a particular kind of Developmental
disorder like you know not usually
autism but usually blindness goes along
with that too they said in fact it's so
common like blindness developmental
disorders and musical prodigy syndrome
like go together so often that they know
that those things must be like close
together in the brain are like related
because they go together a lot which is
weird to think about but I guess it's
just kind of all of a piece but yeah um
that I just that's why Oliver Sacks
could write a whole book about
people with these Savant abilities and
almost all of them were like these
amazing like Musical prodigies that's
one of the most like common things
and another one is a guy named Derek
Amato
who um he actually got a head injury
from he was like horsing around with his
friends uh in the backyard and he
miscalculated and he dived into a
swimming pool into like the shallow end
and he hit his head on the bottom of the
pool and he got a really bad concussion
now he uh he sustained some other
injuries as well he had like some pretty
significant hearing loss too
um but he also suddenly started uh
portraying like having a musical like
Prodigy you know piano now he had
actually had a little bit of musical
experience before
um they said he hadn't played the piano
before but he had played guitar but just
kind of like [__] around playing the
guitar type of thing he wasn't like a
you know he wasn't like Steve Vai or
anything
um and he never really cared about the
piano but uh after he hit his head on
the bottom of the pool
when he was 39 years old uh he suddenly
got this one Obsession to play and
compose piano music and you know this
amazing like thing break and he also
seemed to develop um some synesthesia
which is another thing that you see with
these types of head injury now I know
that some people have it without that
um but synesthesia is another thing
that's it's not super common but it's
not uncommon either like people uh
reporting synesthesia suddenly yeah
explain what synesthesia is for them
it's basically when I'm trying to like
think of the best way to play this I
mean well it's it's when it's like your
senses are kind of like all enmeshed
yeah which with each other like people
who have synesthesia are like oh well
you know the letter F always has like
fur in his purple with dots on it yeah
or smells like cinnamon or something
like that like it's it's like all your
senses are like it sounds crazy but it
actually sounds kind of cool I always
kind of wish I had it to have guys
they're consistent about it you can give
them a number like 3429 he says what is
that and he goes it's a blob that looks
like this it's got a hole over here and
he'll just have this weirdomorphic shape
and he can see it in his head of what
that what that number's shaped like yeah
and then you can test them you can go
back months later and give him that same
number and he'll describe that same
shape again some yeah it looks kind of
like a
looks like a raisin net with two holes
in it and it's over here it's got a
[__] thing that comes out
and there doesn't seem to be any Rhyme
or Reason to it
but
yeah yeah I mean maybe I mean there
might be some kind of underlying
structure that's that would specifically
make you see certain words as certain
smells or something like that this guy
could see it sounds kind of awesome
numbers as shapes yeah and that uh and
then he knew he was good with math
so there'd be like some kind of an
algebraic
equation and he could see what it was
shaped like
and he'd like draw it you know and try
to make a 3D model of what that looked
like which it didn't doesn't make sense
to a normal human but it made a lot of
sense to him he says yeah yeah this is
definitely you know can't you see we're
dividing fractions or we're multiplying
fractions you know can't you see this is
one half times [__] 112th you know
this is it there's the answer you know
weird but see I mean synesthesia that
seems to be also something that people
commonly report like but you know with
on LSD that's that's something so so I
kind of feel like that's maybe an
ability that is in probably the average
human brain but you just don't or can't
access it just in your normal day-to-day
life for whatever reason well like I
said I kind of feel like
I mean it kind of sounds like a bummer
like your brain is an [__] because
your brain is an ad because they're like
suppressing all these like cool
superhuman abilities and stuff like that
but I'm sure there was there's a reason
why it's doing that you know what I'm
saying there was there's usually a
reason why your brain evolved in that
particular way
but you know maybe that's an older
ability that was needed at some point in
our animal past and it's not needed
anymore or it's not generally needed so
it's just kind of like covered up with
other things it could be that I kind of
suspect that that's probably what's
going on because the thing about it is
that when you think of people that
that get these Savant abilities
particularly if it's like mathematical
or if it has to do with like spatial
relationships
um which you know one guy I'm going to
talk about later uh you know has that in
particular I kind of feel like some
animals probably have that and I'm
thinking in particular of
um you know particularly types of
spiders or birds or something like that
where where a lot of their ability to
get food comes from like knowing certain
trajectories and stuff like that so I
imagine I mean we don't know because we
can't tell what they're thinking but I
imagine that maybe that's what the world
looks like to them are they how they
imagine things or that's how they
imagine things and maybe that's kind of
buried deep in our brain too because you
know we're all related to those animals
so all that shit's still in there but
it's just like maybe you can't really
you know we've had all this reasoning
and stuff like that piled on top of our
brains like in the front so it's just
kind of like maybe that's not really
needed as much because we have higher
reasoning functions you know regulation
and all that kind of stuff so it's like
maybe we don't need it but under certain
circumstances it can be like re-release
like it's you know what I mean it's like
this atavistic uh ability I kind of feel
like that's probably what it is animals
definitely imagine oh sure I've seen
pookie
playing with things that aren't there
Chase and stuff that isn't there and is
imagining something to be in there
you know that's pretty complicated it's
complicated we think about that a lot in
terms of Pookie because I guess because
I mean I've had cats before but I think
she's the first cat that we've like
raised from a from a baby yeah she tries
to lie too
yeah you know she'll creep up on
something like don't [__] with that tape
she likes to pull a tape off things
don't [__] the tape then she plays it
off like oh I wasn't going on I said
yeah you were you were gonna do it I saw
you you know I mean huh
[Laughter]
that's lying
we'll remember that one time when
because she knows the rules that it's
like she she loves his Sheba meat sticks
you know and she but she doesn't want to
eat it unless you hold it and you can't
hold it the whole time because she's
trying to eat it she's gonna bite your
finger so it's like sometimes you get
sick of like waiting like your arm gets
tired so you put it down on the ground
and then she gets mad but then she'll
come back later and she wants a new one
yeah and she knows the rules we tell her
no you have to eat the old one before we
give you a new one yeah and a couple of
times she is actually sat on the old one
to hide to hide it and then like beg for
a new one like hey there see there's
nothing there yeah now what about that
one just oh oh [__] you caught me
so deception in line anyway so we
thought to myself like yeah so I kind of
feel like this is kind of going into
what I was talking about about maybe
some of these abilities being maybe not
being like superhuman but maybe being
atavistic maybe like a lot of animals
see the world in this particular way but
because we have all these higher
functions quote unquote like all this
reasoning and stuff that maybe some
animals don't have
um maybe it's like you know the brain's
like oh we don't really need that
anymore so it just got buried under
other stuff but you can still access it
in certain circumstances because I kind
of feel like animals are a lot more
intelligent or a lot clever a lot more
cunning than we give them credit for and
they yeah like you said deception
imagination those are pretty high
functioning I mean you wouldn't really I
think maybe a hundred years ago I don't
think people thought of animals as
having those abilities but they
absolutely do and I think that if
anybody has you know if everybody has
pets like cats or dogs or something like
that
um you know you can see them do those
kinds of things you know and I'm sure
like some of them are more intelligent
than others just like people but I mean
Pokey very obviously
uh tries to deceive us
um you know she feels shame and anger
and she feels like the same emotions
that we have and she definitely tries to
manipulate and she also
um very clearly imagines things that
aren't there like when she's playing and
stuff like that like she's there's
nothing there but she's like pretending
oh it's a mouse you know what I mean so
so like I said that's pretty Advanced a
more advanced I think than people would
give animals uh credit for
so um so yeah so let's talk about this
other guy whose name is uh Patrick
fagerberg now he used he started as a
lawyer actually
um but you know then then this kind of
[__] happened
so he was actually from Mexico although
his dad was uh American his dad was like
some kind of uh like a indie film
producer guy
um and he had like a bunch of siblings
they kind of were homeless for a while
or whatever and for a while fegerberg um
was actually a professional soccer
player in Germany but uh he got a knee
injury so he had to retire and then like
he ended up going to law school and
becoming a lawyer
now interestingly what happened after
that was that fairly recent
um in 2011
uh fakerberg was um at the South by
Southwest uh festival and he was seeing
a concert by OMD uh orchestral Maneuvers
in the dark which uh you know New Wave
band very good band actually if you've
never heard of them but he uh went to
see them
and um a couple minutes after the
concert began a 400 pound camera boom
fell on his head
and it knocked him out for a few minutes
uh so obviously he got taken to the
hospital and they did a bunch of CT
scans and everything like that but they
didn't see any Dam like his neck wasn't
broken like he didn't seem to have any
skull fractures or anything like that so
basically they're like okay well here's
some painkillers and you know call us in
the morning pretty much they're like we
don't see anything to matter with you
even though a 400 pound thing just fell
on your head
um and he was okay for two days but then
um after a couple days had gone by he
started uh he couldn't he was having
trouble reading and he was having
trouble talking like his uh Speech was
all garbled
and then he started having uh bleeding
from the ears that's that's never good
and uh his eyes started looking all
funny
and uh so he's like okay well obviously
this isn't right so he went back to the
hospital and then at that point they
found a very very small skull fracture
um you know that they had not spotted
before uh but it was pretty traumatic a
traumatic brain injury so at that point
he actually had to spend the next about
18 months uh doing cognitive therapy
speech therapy and everything like that
because his you know cognitive abilities
had begun to decline because of this uh
you know brain injury
uh he did Sue later on so it was fine
and he actually at met Andy McCluskey
from OMD like on his Wikipedia page as a
picture of him and Annie McCluskey from
OMD which I thought was funny
um now interestingly when he was at one
of the cognitive therapy sessions where
they were trying to like you know help
him out with this they suggested and
they start they suggest this to a lot of
uh people with these types of traumatic
brain injuries to do uh art therapy
and so he started taking these classes
and again he had this very obsessive
need to start painting he wasn't
interested in painting he'd never
painted before or drawn or anything like
that but he suddenly was like holy [__]
I gotta paint
um and he started getting real into
Edvard Monk and uh Vincent van Gogh
stuff like that
and then he started doing his own stuff
and uh basically just like in the case
of uh Alonzo the sculptor before
um he just started producing these
beautiful uh you know artworks that you
know attracted the attention of gallery
owners and stuff like that and
eventually
um he started selling them like all over
the world in Galleries and I've seen
some of his art it's abstract it's like
non-representational but it actually is
quite beautiful like a lot of it
reminded me of um like glaciers like it
kind of looks like
I don't know it's like it's really it's
I don't know it's kind of cool looking
but it's like hard to explain but uh
yeah so he actually uh did kind of find
a new career as an artist because of
that he also this is interesting too and
I don't know if he was had a particular
invention uh or interest in inventing
things before but he has also invented
um an electric vehicle it's essentially
a surfboard for the land is what it is
it's kind of well it's kind of like I've
seen it it's actually kind of cool but
it's like it's kind of like a skateboard
but it's more like
um he actually invented the first
electric vehicle to use asymmetrical
wheel placement because he wanted it to
simulate
um the experience of riding on a
surfboard except on the land right so he
invented that and it's called the
rotisserf okay and uh yeah so I guess
he's got he lives in Austin Texas so
it's like he's been all over the media
there and apparently it's like pretty
neat
um now again see because this isn't all
like
[__] you know Sunshine of rainbows
like getting these kind of cool new
abilities and everything like that it's
like oh I can invent things in like
vehicle artists and everything like that
however uh because of his traumatic
brain injury which like I said did cause
him some uh difficulties as well he
actually developed a cocaine addiction
which was pretty bad in fact it was so
bad
this is okay this is how you know that
you take too much cocaine if you were
taking so much cocaine that the
authorities think that you are a
supplier but no she's like no that's all
me
um yeah then you're taking too fast you
must have been Rich well he was a lawyer
to start with so I guess he had like
some money well I guess he got it well
and because he sued the um you know the
concert goers like for that thing
falling on his head and rightfully so
okay so he had like us he got a big
settlement for that
so and he and he blew it all on coke
which like I said that's funny not the
best idea but it must have had a little
bit of a habit before that should happen
maybe because I can't imagine it you're
sitting there boom you get hit on the
head and you shake this [__] God damn I
need some coke I just can't I don't know
maybe
yeah I mean it's good he was he was
hoovering it all up apparently
yeah the authorities they actually
thought that he was like at the Hub of
some big distribution thing and they
were like no that was just that's just
him snorting that [__] up yeah he was
like that was [__] Tony Montana [__]
right there he just had like a pile of
it on the desk that [__] is too
expensive that's just too [__]
expensive
Zach says taking too much coke Richard
Pryor hold my tube yeah right
yeah
um but yeah so that's that's not great
that was like a bad side effect
um and he did actually get arrested uh
in 2014 because like I said they thought
that he was the Hub of this big like
distribution network but he wasn't it
was just him and they were just like
damn dude dial it back a little bit but
that's not what they said but you know
that's what I said
um also he got arrested well I don't
know if he got arrested but he got in
trouble again sort of in 2018
um which and and this I don't think was
entirely his fault because there was a
guy apparently that was like speeding
down his the street where he lived like
at 90 miles an hour and almost ran this
guy's kid over
and so like I said not rightfully so
probably like he chased the Dude down
and like you know [__] the dude's car
up and punch the dude in the face which
like I said the dude probably deserved
it so you know
so I don't know if they want to do
attribute that to like his head injury
I'm like no that's just like sounds like
some regular [__] that you would do you
almost run over my kid yeah I'm gonna
punch you in your face too you know what
I mean so you know
um so I thought I was gonna say
something else but it's like oh Camp guy
said lots of serial killers had head
injuries when they were younger yeah see
that's the thing I kind of feel like you
get a head injury it's either it's like
oh wow now I'm a musical genius or oh
[__] no I'm a serial killer there's like
no in between
I kind of feel like it's probably it's
probably mostly in between you just
don't hear about those well yeah you
just don't hear about it yeah that's a
yeah and I'm just I'm making a joke
really those are just like the two
extremes and I'm gonna say I don't have
any statistical uh you know any
statistics to back this up I'm just
pulling it right out of my butt but I do
kind of feel like maybe it's probably
because Savant syndrome is so rare I'm
gonna say it's probably more common
serial killer is probably more common
but it says it's still not that common
you know you hear about it more that's
for sure
yeah so I kind of feel like most of the
time if you get a head injury like like
98 of the time it's bad and even some of
these people because like I said some of
these people that got head injuries and
they got these amazing abilities they
get some pretty [__] up [__] happen
too because like look at poor Alonso you
know what I mean like that [__] up his
whole like yeah he's probably happy and
he can sculpt and he's amazing and all
that other kind of stuff but it's like I
don't know
you know he was too young when it
happened for him to like have any choice
in the matter but I don't know if that
if he would consider it worth it if he
could go back and do it over again you
know what I'm saying and I kind of feel
like that's the case with a lot of these
but yeah so
um we're talking about uh this next guy
this is another guy that I want to talk
about this
um what uh how long an hour and 24
minutes okay it's time for commercials
okay let's do do some commercials people
okay and then um then we'll finish on
this next case so we'll do almost do
this next case
trying to keep the show on around two
hours yeah okay Midway we're gonna do
commercials yeah because I probably have
to like go to bed too but you know what
I mean because I got up to right and
then I gotta I gotta finish the Carnitas
oh that's right yeah all right so we'll
do a couple of commercials and then
we'll come back and talk about uh this
last guy and then we'll kind of like
talk about the yeah the stuff in general
because like I said I found this a
really interesting topic and read a lot
of papers on it so I thought it was kind
of cool all right so we're gonna do some
commercials and we'll be right back in
just a minute
oh
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
walls
[Music]
death
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
let me do good
all right we're back
ladies and gentlemen uh yeah so
Zach says or get a head injury oh [__]
I'm dead yeah I kind of feel like like I
said 98 of the time you get a head
injury it's it's mostly a bad thing I'm
gonna say um I don't really know as neat
as it would be to like be a musical
genius I don't know if I'd want to go
through all the others not mostly a bad
thing it is a bad thing that yeah I
think these abilities that people could
have that have that they picked up
through head injuries you can induce
that you can induce them into yourself
probably through training
or drugs or electrodes yeah I kind of
feel like there's probably better ways
to go about it then that's why I'm kind
of like I'm reading for them to get into
that electromagnetic uh kind of thing
where they can because like I said they
can do it temporarily it's not quite as
uh amazing as what you would usually see
in a natural Savant Center or somebody
that got it through injury but it's
along the same lines but it doesn't last
that long but I kind of feel like if
they keep going in that direction then
they'll be able to induce it maybe
safely yeah okay we're gonna do this
case here and Jenny told me to remind
her to get into the male female brain
different stuff that she wants to talk
about what else did you want to talk
about well I just want to make these two
cases like I said I just know we know
the difference between well no I just
want well the incidents the difference
in the incident yeah it's interesting to
me it was interesting to me yeah and
they have like they don't know exactly
why but they have some theories okay it
might be
um but yeah so a couple more cases there
was a guy named uh Orlando Sorel
and he actually when he was 10 years old
he was out playing with his friends and
he got hit in the head with a baseball
um and he didn't uh this was in 1979 and
he didn't actually tell anybody like he
didn't tell his parents or anything like
that so he didn't go to the hospital or
nothing uh so basically he just had a
headache for uh a long time but didn't
tell anybody I mean that sounds like
some [__] I would have done when I was a
kid
um now the headache eventually went away
but after the headache went away uh he
found that he had
um almost perfect uh he had he could do
the calendar thing and he had almost
perfect uh recall of his entire life
like every day like what had happened
every single day what he wore what he
ate uh what the weather was like um all
that kind of stuff like every single day
of his life so again a lot of these
Savant things have to do the underlying
thing is like memory having like
prodigious memory so it's obviously
something to do with that particular and
it's usually the injuries almost always
to like the left side of the brain the
left hemisphere the left frontal lobe
almost always
um but like I said it's too
they know where to stimulate it to
replicate the ability to a small extent
and it's temporary so they do know
roughly like where it has to happen
now there's also the case of a guy named
Jason Padgett and I think he did a TED
talk as well it's I think it's probably
on YouTube
um I saw a documentary about like a
short documentary about him as well
what happened to him
um he's about our age he was born in
1970.
and he was kind of like just an average
guy you know what I mean it's like he
started going to college he dropped out
like his dad owned a futon company so he
became a futon salesman because he just
couldn't be bothered like doing anything
else right
so what happened to him though in 2002
on Friday the 13th actually in September
he went out with some of his friends to
like a karaoke bar
in Tacoma Washington outside of the bar
he got mugged uh two guys jumped him and
they hit him on the back of the head and
he fell on the ground
he said all he could make he didn't
remember paying or anything like that he
remembered a bright white light he said
it looked like a photo camera flash
um and the feeling of the whole world
spinning
so he basically fell and went
unconscious
and then when he woke up
um he tried to stand up but the two guys
were still there and they just kept like
punching him and kicking him and stuff
like that they actually the stupid thing
about it was that then we'll get into
like because they he found out like who
they were later but they I guess they
were like drug addicts I guess they were
trying to rob him but they didn't take
his wallet which had a bunch of money in
it but they did take his leather jacket
and they just like beat the [__] out of
him and gave him a horrible head injury
so you know uh so yeah
so he goes to the hospital and he had a
really bad um like his kidney was all
kind of [__] up like bruised and
everything because they've been kicking
him and he had like a really really bad
uh concussion
so they they thought that was the only
problem so they just gave him medication
and like sent him home uh they did
arrest the two guys but they got
released later on uh you know so and he
met one of them later on too but we'll
get into that
so they said the day after this even
though they hadn't found any specific
like really bad injuries like on the MRI
or anything
um he said he started feeling really
weird
um and at first he thought that it was
maybe the medication that they had put
him on
but uh as time went on he started to
realize something uh different was going
on now
he had some cool [__] happen but he also
developed uh OCD
um he became a germaphobe which uh he
said that wasn't great but um like he
doesn't like to touch people or anything
like that because he thinks everybody's
like crawling with disease which you
know they probably are but how do you
have sex well I don't know yeah
um and he had PTSD uh also
so so he had like that hand wash like
obsessive hand washing and stuff like
that like I said he that that wasn't
great and uh also he didn't like
um sunlight like touching him so he had
to like put blankets over the windows
and stuff like that
um so and and he started sleeping a lot
which that's pretty common with like
head injuries I feel like and they said
that this he said this particular thing
like the OCD the PTSD like the being
afraid of sunlight the sleeping for days
at a time that happened for like that
went on for like three years
but one thing that he said was actually
pretty cool and actually he's glad that
it happened
this happened like very shortly after
the accident he started seeing the world
entirely in
shapes fractals he started seeing the
world essentially geometrically so like
I said this is kind of like what I was
talking about when I said that maybe
people when these abilities are unlocked
they're seeing the world in an atavistic
kind of way like the way an animal would
see it where he said he couldn't see
he's like everything looks a little bit
pixelated but he can kind of see he's
like when I see for example like water
swirling down a drain he sees tangents
like line tangents and he can see so
it's almost like he's seeing everything
from like a geometric like he sees
everything like in lines and shapes
weird and so he started to understand
even though he hadn't really been all
that great uh math student before but he
started understanding the all the
underlying principles underneath like
mathematics and physics and everything
like that which he had never understood
before but it seemed all come very
naturally because that was how he saw
the world now and remember how I said
earlier like the guy that Alonso the guy
that sculpted and they said that it
might be that the part of it the part of
your brain that like Smooths out your
visual uh input to like make it look
like a continuous thing
um they think that maybe that was
damaged so that he sees everything in
just very discreet like snapshots
essentially
um and he kind of described it like that
too he's like he sees everything as a
click click click click click like
little but it's like which is [__] up
but it's like that's how he sees
everything now and it made him like
understand mathematics a lot better
weird which is crazy
um so he also and he also kind of
developed an artistic ability because he
uh developed an obsession with drawing
out what he saw like so he draws like
all these geometric kind of Concepts and
the interesting thing was that he hadn't
really thought too much about it he was
just drawing how the world looked to him
now and it so happened that somebody you
know he was outside at a park or
something drawing something in his book
and somebody walked by and was like what
are you doing and he said something
about you know planks constant or
something like that and the guy's like
hey I'm a physicist and you know that
has something to do with pie or whatever
and he was just like oh well that makes
a lot of sense so then he like went and
started taking math classes so he could
like understand
um you know so he could get like a kind
of a context for what it was that he was
seeing but he started seeing the world
like that so that kind of interested me
because I'm like because remember like I
said you know like a like a spider that
builds a web or you know a particular
kind of birds or something like that
that have to you know do all these
complicated trajectories and stuff I was
like maybe that's how they see the world
too
but our brains have smoothed everything
over for us so we don't see that anymore
but maybe that part of his brain was
damaged and now he's seeing the world
like that almost robotic yeah and he
actually
um you know he like I said he didn't
love the OCD and all that but he was
just kind of like but that part of it
he's like that was you know took some
getting used to obviously because he
sees her he's like everything looks
slightly pixelated can he drive
um I don't know
I don't know he seems to have like a
pretty normal life I mean it seemed like
from at least from what I could
determine from the documentary that I
saw but he really he he kind of dug it
he was like I kind of
he kind of saw it as like a gift I guess
um and he's you know gone on to do
artwork as well and he's actually been
able to sell that too and has you know
given TED talks and sold books and
whatnot and like I said one of the guys
that mugged him that that beat the [__]
out of him
um 15 years later
that guy like contacted him
and said and like apologized and said
that you know he was [__] up on drugs
and it's like I didn't you know I feel
really terrible that I did that to you
and [__] like that so it's like they
kind of like I don't know if they became
friends or anything like that but he's
like that was actually really pretty
cool that like that that guy I don't
know about the other guy the other guy
probably just was just an [__] still
but um
um but yeah oh interestingly too this
guy and they said this on the
documentary that I was watching
um using his mathematical ability he
decided because he was from Tacoma
Washington and him and his wife and kids
they were like they wanted to move and
so he said I'm going to write a program
like a mathematical formula to figure
out where the best place to live is so
he plugged in like all of the um you
know the algorithms of like what they
wanted and came up with Carmel Indiana
that was the place where they ended up
moving well that was the place that the
program that he wrote he wrote a program
to find the best place for them to live
like based on all these parameters and
that's where and he said they moved
there and he said he loved it there okay
they'd never been there before all right
he just like he's like well
mathematically that's the best place to
go so that's where they went I just
thought that was kind of funny and he
brought that up but yeah so I wanted to
get a little bit into
uh there is interestingly and I we might
have mentioned enough in the autism show
as well there is kind of a very large
disparity between
um incidences of not only uh autism
autism spectrum disorders but also
Savant syndrome uh between males and
females now uh autism spectrum disorder
um generally they say that it's usually
four to one uh male to female
that could be
um either because that's the true thing
or because females don't get uh
diagnosed with it as often because it
doesn't manifest quite the same uh so
I'm not really sure about that Savant
syndrome though is six to one uh male to
female
now they're like in in terms of
congenital Savant syndrome uh as in
either people with Autism Spectrum
disorders that have Savant abilities or
people that have other developmental
disorders or whatever that are born
these abilities
they think that it might be
um that
what happens is that the okay so the
left side of your brain the left
hemisphere of your brain
develops more slowly than the right
hemisphere
and in male babies
uh you know they sometimes they have
kind of like high levels of testosterone
um you know swishing around in there
and if there is a sufficiently high
level of testosterone it can cause
damage to the left side of the brain for
a longer amount of time because the left
side of the brain is still developing
because it takes longer to develop you
know what I mean yeah also there might
be something and I don't I didn't read
this in a paper but I just kind of like
came up with this because of something
that I read before now remember the guy
that I was talking about that the guy um
that rain man was based on like the guy
that could do
um that was he was actually kind of uh
born like that and he could do with all
the [__] with the maps and everything
like he could tell you all around the
cities and stuff that guy when they did
an MRI later on if I remember correctly
he didn't actually have a corpus
callosum hmm
um and we've talked about this before I
think that sometimes in people that have
like severe epilepsy for example
sometimes they will sever the corpus
callosum
um in order to because it's causing like
over did you get a split then you have
split split brain syndrome which is
actually another really fascinating I
don't think we've done a show no I want
to because I think that relates to
Poltergeist I mean yeah because that's
like super interesting too yeah
and it's and it's kind of relevant to
what we're saying too because the thing
about it and this is not you know this
is generally true but generally uh
women's Brains have larger uh Corpus
callosums than men's Brains do in
general like not always obviously
there's uh you know many many variations
yeah it's very hip right now to to think
that gender or the differences between
male and female or just some kind of
social construct they are not they're
biological I've been there uh your
biology [__] produces different
hormones and I've been in hyper
masculine States because of the [__]
exogenous hormone use I've done and I've
also [__] been in pregnant Superman
state where your guts more progesterone
in you than a man should ever have well
you got more progesterone in you than a
pregnant woman and it Alters it Alters
how you operate how you think and how
you perceive everything
so the differences between male and
female are also just hormonal I've been
under the influence of those and they're
they're not the same well much much like
much like brain science yeah it's very
plastic it's not it's not as I I kind of
feel like the problem comes with people
that try to put people into these boxes
it's like this is male this is female
it's like it's not exactly like it's a
spectrum just like everything else males
are not stable neither are females a guy
and is going through his teenage years
looks very different than a dude in his
80s or his 70s okay because his hormone
production is way low he's more
androgynous okay that he is male at that
point uh and the differences between a
teenage male and a team teenage female
they're pretty pretty big difference all
right um that they're flooded with two
very different hormonal profiles and the
other things that you just said is just
you know the the way the brain's
constructed is different
as far as I'm you know I'm not a nurse
neuroscientist obviously as far as I
have read it's not necessarily the
structure of the brain that's different
necessarily it's the connections in the
brain that are different or like the
structure of the connections yeah it's
pretty important though one day yeah it
is but I'm just saying like the brains
are pretty much the same yeah
um but it's just kind of like and the
thing about it too is that what they see
a lot of times in people with Autism
Spectrum disorders people with Savant
syndrome or you know both is that what
they think is happening is that
generally because generally male brains
tend to be more have more like local
connections whereas women's Brains tend
to have more overall like big picture
type of connections
um they think that you know if you have
damage in one part of your brain like
you'll kind of have more local
connections like spring up in this one
so it'll cause these obsessive
um but like amazing abilities in one
very narrow particular area whereas they
you don't see that in women as much
because their brains are a lot more
integrated I guess is maybe the worst
men are far more prone to obsessive
Behavior far more
because we can focus in on one small
little thing and get off on that for
[__] years you know and in extreme
cases you have dudes that are just they
all they want to do is just talk about
cameras
you know ever the models of every camera
is what the serial numbers were just you
know that's some lame [__] but that's
just something that males who are
[__] real
um like autistic will do which autism
seems to be almost kind of like a some
kind of a hyper masculine
mind state it's probably organic too
something going on in there as I said
there I kind of feel like
um women have it too but I kind of feel
like either they have it less or it's
under diagnosed because it doesn't
manifest quite the same possibly so
differences between gender differences
of course you know [__] it's not hip
to talk about them I think it's totally
ridiculous because the differences
between people's what makes the human
spectrum and male and females are
different they're supposed to be there's
nothing wrong with either one of them
that's they're they're doing what
they're supposed to do they just
specialize for two different tasks and
that's and we we we inherited these
tasks through the animal kingdom they're
not even human a lot of the stuff that
guys do other a lot of stuff that males
do males do that same [__] behavior
in in non-human species you know what I
mean we've inherited a lot of that just
from other animals and a lot of the
stuff that we even everything we are
we've basically inherited from animals
well as I said we're still animals yeah
um we just have a couple layers of like
cooler [__] on top right so well
actually I don't even know if it's
cooler it might not be cooler because a
lot of times it just causes anxiety it's
better not to know and just do [__] and
live your life and reproduce and die
almost in a state of Illinois just just
enjoying your life I don't know I don't
know I I struggle with this a lot
because I am a classic overthinker so I
have like a lot of anxiety about stuff
because I'm constantly thinking about
the 40 bajillion possibilities of um you
know how everything can go terribly
terribly wrong so it's like you know
it's not fun to live like that but I
don't really know
I thought to myself before I was like
would it be better if I was just like
dumb and like didn't worry about it if
you're a cat or you're a dog or you're I
don't know if I'd want to be like that
though it's not fun being like this but
I don't really like the other
possibility either I got a feeling that
animals are basically mentally in the
Garden of Eden
basically I don't know though I don't
know about that they do suffer and they
die in the end a lot of them are eaten
alive that's how a lot of them die
but
they're going to sell when that happens
they kind of check out and have an
out-of-body experience you know humans
kind of do the same thing when you're
experiencing too much pain or shock or
anguish you just kind of check out
and that's you can look into the eyes of
a zebra that's being basically eaten
alive by lions and eyes are rolling up
in the back of its head and they're like
man that thing's insult you know which
is something that horses can go into
that mental state just start checking
out
and I guess it's something that you're
just they just evolved with the ability
to just leave [__] it game over well the
thing about it is that
I mean for every that's the thing it's
like every time you can think of like
you know oh well that's just your
brain's way of just like you know yeah
I'm checking out it's like to to save
you from the trauma yeah but for every
case of that that you can think of you
can think of like other cases of people
that went through really horrible [__]
and remembered every excruciating second
of it yeah so it's not that's the thing
about humans is that well and even
animals too like to a great extent were
so complex
though well we're so complex that it's
like no one person there's no Universal
experience it's like yeah a lot of our
experiences are similar but everybody
experiences the world in a slightly
different way which is fascinating
because like I said some people you know
go through a really traumatic thing and
it's just like oh I just forgot all
about it but it's some people just
remember every bit of it which is
probably not good for you but I think
it's weird you know I've heard people
saying that you know question whether or
not there's free will and I've always
thought yeah there is free will but then
once I heard it kind of explaining yeah
maybe there isn't because all you're
doing is is you're going through a
mental process of your you're you're
being presented with with a problem and
then your intelligence comes up with
Solutions and you consistently pick the
best solution the one that you think is
the best yeah not necessarily the best
like objectively you think is best now
if you were more intelligent you might
come up with a couple more a couple
different solutions that would be even
better but you weren't that intelligent
so you didn't choose those
so basically everything we're doing is
systematic almost kind of like an
program
but do you actually have the will to
choose no because I tend to choose the
best or what I think is the best I never
say wait you know what option A is the
best one but [__] it I'm gonna choose
option C just to show that I have free
without you know I mean you don't do
that probably some people probably do
well that's what I'm saying there's lots
of maths that you just don't really
that's not how you're operating though
no I'm just well the thing about it I I
read a couple books about this like
several years ago and I kind of came
down on the thing it's like well do we
technically do we have free will no
but we have the illusion of Free Will
and honestly it's it amounts to pretty
much the same thing yeah it's so close
that I really don't think we should
worry over much about it yeah don't
think about it because well no because
well I thought to myself like when it
was explained I was just kind of like
yeah but
if you I mean if you think you're
choosing then you're choosing it's not
just don't think about it too hard you
know and I know that's kind of hard to
say anytime I remember choosing it's
because the choices were so close
together that they were amounted to be
about the same
that I remember choosing between that
like you know what these choices are all
about the same
which one might be a little bit better
that's the only time I'd ever I'd ever
really that you're ever really conscious
yeah usually because usually something
is like pretty obviously so obvious like
one is way better yeah yeah right
so yeah and I mean usually if if you're
in a situation like that where like the
choices are so it's usually something
that's not really all that important
yeah
right that's what I mean like yeah I
have a hard time deciding on that it's
like what do I feel like eating it's
like I've got two flounders and a red
fish which one
I mean the thing about it is that well
even when the choices are very disparate
I still have a hard time it's like what
do I feel like I don't know you know
what I mean but like I said that's not
real I mean you're still eating food too
it's not really like that significant
you know a a thing to think about so I
don't know I kind of feel like if it's a
big life-changing thing that it's
usually pretty
easy to like choose something but I
don't know but it's so okay
um
so we talked about this a little bit
earlier but
if somehow and I kind of hope they are
working on this if if we can't have
teleportation for Christ's sake because
that's my that's my number one go-to
like please somebody do teleportation
that'd be so [__] awesome somebody
said no it's socialization there's no
context there man we don't know what
you're referring to well they might be
talking about well here's the thing I
kind of feel like I don't think it's one
or the other what you don't know um for
some people like um I guess like
particular like gender of the brain and
things like that or like you know
differences between men and women and
blah blah
it's not just one or the other it's like
everything else
um and we talk about this on like a lot
of the serial killer shows because I
think always people want to come down on
like oh it's nature oh it's nurture it's
not it's it's both things and it's uh an
enmeshed uh combination like a feedback
loop of both things like feeding off of
each other and you can't ever tease them
apart and I kind of feel like this is a
situation like that because the thing
about it is that you know you could be
the most quote unquote traditionally
masculine whatever that means for your
particular culture uh born but it's like
you know had you been born in a
different culture where different you
know things it might manifest in a
different way I think it's constantly
like a push and pull like between what
your innate biological abilities are
what your uh expression is and what how
the culture is reacting to you so it's
just it because your brain like I said
changes I'm gonna say yeah you're right
but you're only talking you're only
you're only talking about within normal
parameter okay well yeah obviously I I
only think pretty much in extremes all
right that's where I find the truth you
give me this dude who's just a normal
guy for his little let's say somewhere
in Japan or something where they're
pretty sedate you give him to me and I
start pumping him up with a bunch of
[__] anabolic steroids Trend a [__]
ton of [__] testosterone and send him
back into Japan he's gonna get into a
lot of [__] trouble
all right and it's not really a choice
it's just now he's extremely aggressive
very dominant and he's done he's not
choosing well as I mentioned he'll go
back there and I'll have him he'll be a
[__] tiger when I'm done with him
well like I said you know end up in
prison we've talked about this a lot in
the context of serial killers in
particular because we do a lot of True
Crime shows and I've kind of come to the
conclusion that it's never just one
thing it's always a combination of
things and I think this is no different
yeah
um you're always just kind of like with
a serial killer like people said oh that
a lot of times they have head injuries
or a lot of times they were abused as
children like a lot of times they were
some of them weren't
um but the thing about it is like could
you take an a person that was normal
quote unquote neurotypical when they
were born and through systematic
uh uh brainwashing if you want to call
it that or abuse or something like that
could you turn him into a serial killer
probably
um but maybe not because I don't think
everybody
has the capacity
to become that this I've said this
before on earlier shows if you guys have
listened long enough some of you guys
have
always wondered some of these extremely
sadistic serial killers I'd want to get
some of that I want to get a blood
sample from them dudes and do a [__]
a whole bunch look real closely at their
endocrine system and see if they are
actually producing testosterone and that
testosterone molecule
is it normal testosterone or is it or is
it a mutant variant that looks more like
say an anabolic steroid like Trend or
Trenbolone that would make a huge
difference a big difference
because I got very aggressive on that
and there's a lot of [__] psychotic
ideations you're very
ruthless
um I was gonna say sadistic earlier yeah
when I was talking about the uh the
higher the much higher incidence of
savant syndrome in uh in males than
females
um and they said that a lot that some of
that they're not entirely sure if this
is what it was but this is kind of like
the going Theory is that because male
brains are so often steeped in a lot of
testosterone like when they're in the
womb
um that it might be causing damage
because please don't take this the wrong
way but testosterone in some ways is
kind of a poison like it does actually
cause a son of damage uh you know not
the way that you might be thinking yeah
um but it does cause uh damage in
particular areas and there are things it
does damage particular areas of the
brain because there are other uh kind of
neurological disorders that are very
very much more um you know manifested in
male brain so uh dyslexia
um stuttering things like that much much
more common but she's talking about what
is this
foreign
in all humans you're a mixture of a
bunch of hormones but the male profile
on the female profile looks very
different in a male
we have estrogen all right and estrogen
is what's called neuroprotective it can
somehow protect neurons from the effects
of the other of the other hormones
um the other hormones [__] can go in
there like testosterone and they can
signal and it's not necessarily brain
damage what it is it's more like
mind-altering that's a better way to put
it
um because it's not destroying those
cells it's just firing them
can get you to do things
when I was on Trend I almost had no
estrogen
and it you can't sleep so you don't you
don't sleep very well you never enter
REM sleep
um you're hyper vigilant
um and my testosterone was levels are
probably about probably about three or
four times higher than a teenager's
with a [__] ton of progesterone probably
as much as a pregnant woman it was not a
good combo no if you're new here
it allows you to do a lot of stuff but
you like you like it after a while I got
to where I didn't feel it but it it
makes everybody else miserable because
they don't really they can't predict
what you're going to do yeah because
you're like a crazy person you're
currently clinically insane yeah you can
control it it's like living with a crazy
person you can control it but your
feelings are just [__] it's like a
roller coaster yeah you're which like I
said
um you know I I've
some of the stuff that you described
when you were on that yeah I was like
what's the big deal I felt like that my
whole entire life yeah but see a lot of
times like women have felt like that
their whole entire life so they can
manage it because it's like oh well this
is just like Monday morning like I said
right but for you don't feel that for
you it was uh it was a new experience
and a woman I was like welcome to my
world [__] yeah women would be
shocked to know that yeah we don't feel
like y'all not at all and when when you
start having that self-doubt and picking
yourself apart and you're you're you're
attacking the self and you're totally
unsure of [__] dudes don't do that my
whole life dudes don't do that maybe
they should no they can't
it's it's destructive baby it's
destructive it's not good well no I
think I think
um to a small degree like to a large
degree yeah if you do it all the time
yeah I agree that is destruction because
I buy things that are not real well I
think some sometimes though that
everybody needs to have that because it
comes from introspection and I don't
think you should just go out in the
world [__] swinging and be like oh I can
do everything and I'm [__] awesome at
all times because then you're just gonna
do whatever the [__] you want you're
just gonna [__] everyone else over thank
you I hate your guts thank you so that's
what I mean and nobody else you don't
care right and it's like nobody likes
that nobody wants to be around that
person you'd end up winning well I mean
you're happy but everyone else around
you hates you and it's miserable well
yeah you don't care you don't care
because you don't have to deal with it
so that's about that's your see that
that's but that's the point that I'm
better for you to go it's a lot better
but that's the point that I'm making
it's a lot better for you as an
individual guy to go through life like a
tank and just [__] take what you want
and get what you want don't even worry
about it and you protect people that you
care about but everybody else [__] them
and and a lot of guys are like that yeah
but like I said I don't like that though
women are about fairness and sharing and
caring and nurturing of children dudes
just when when you're when you're at a
very high testosterone State yeah that's
not even really in your your you protect
women and children that belong to you
[__] other people's women and children
those aren't yours nobody belongs to you
yeah but that's the thinking it's you've
mated with this we don't know this is
but that is the thinking that's how it
feels and that's what it seems like it's
hormones
Zach said I'm already kind of like that
and I hate it yeah well I'm imagining
that uh he's talking about yeah I mean
I've been like that my whole life I
don't really know any other way to be I
don't know I don't like it or dislike it
it's just kind of like that's what I'm
like
but I don't think there's any right and
wrong in any of this I don't moralize
anything I'm not religious I don't
believe in any even political religions
I only believe in what works
and for millions of years this has
worked even in non-humans
um we're only in a temporary state of
Civilization now anyway if you look at
human history it just comes and goes
we'll be Savages in another hundred
thousand years anyway it won't matter
you know what I mean well I mean the
thing about it though is that if you
choose to live in a society
um and you act like you seem to want to
act then somebody's eventually gonna
[__] take your ass out it's the same
way in nature though
and if you're fine with that then but
like well we only well I mean you know
but people don't want to like hang with
you like because people don't want to
live with you if you're like that
no I don't think that's true people like
you don't people hang out with me
people don't hang out with me I mean
they kind of do yeah but it's like I
don't I don't know I don't know if they
know that you're really like this I
don't worry you just don't give a [__]
about anybody I don't worry about it you
know I just but I think most guys are
like that
like I said I'm not saying I don't think
it's good to worry about everything
because I'm like that and it's like it's
not great but it's like I said I don't
hate it I don't like it I don't dislike
it that's just like what I'm like and I
just deal with it yeah but I don't I
wouldn't want to be like you though at
all well you don't have to be like me
because I'm doing it well that's what I
said well I even if I it's been the the
tasks have been divided you know what I
mean well I don't see the need for why
why I don't see the need for you to be
like that though
like why why would you need to be like
that I don't know I didn't have in any
situation I've always been like that no
I'm just saying like as far as task
Division I was like why why would you
need to
why why would I need anybody to just be
not care about anybody
that's
not I don't need that that's not a
question
no just more security minded and
watching out for myself and other people
that I care about and just trying to
um uh gain and you know you want to win
you don't want to lose it's just that's
that's that's the thinking and I don't
question it if I start questioning it
then the system breaks down
and then you go like this dude's a loser
and then you replace me with another one
that's not how it's gonna work but okay
okay
we'll see if I start to act like a simpy
ass [__] you'd [__] have me out of
here and you'd have some other
[__] here watching out for you
no one watches out for me Jenny watches
out for Jenny okay Jenny watches out for
Jenny yeah okay
we'll see I've always been like that all
right okay we'll see how you do on your
own then I'm just saying it's okay Jenny
watches out for Jenny okay I don't think
about I don't think about I don't think
about you in terms of like when that
watching out for me when that dude had
you down on the ground on a dance floor
I was trying to get to you right all
right okay let's let's back up a second
yeah
he only tackled me because you pulled
him off and were like beating the [__]
out of him prior to that he wasn't he
hadn't attacked me he was just like
hanging around creepy yeah he's being
creep you know I just [__] pushed him
had you not been there like if like for
example it had it just been me and
Sophie yeah um we would have just like
kept dancing moved somewhere else and
then just like somebody else would have
done it somebody else somebody else
would have had yeah but like yeah but he
wouldn't have tackled me though because
I wouldn't have been there you thought
you were me that's what I mean so it's
like it wasn't it wasn't like he just
like he tackled me and then you jumped
yeah I'll tell you what next time
there's a problem you're on your own no
I'm just looking at you no I'm just
telling you that's what that's right
next time somebody rings the doorbell
tries to come in the house in the middle
of the night don't [__] hand me the
pistol and go so you see who that is I'm
gonna hand you the pistol and say you go
see who it is that's not gonna happen
yeah okay all right we're gonna see you
go check him out
you're taking this totally the wrong way
that's what exactly go restroom well the
tip
okay
I mean I was trying I was gonna try and
end the show but okay uh yeah so we seem
to have wandered pretty far away from
like what else is new
um from the topic but I think that was
pretty much all I have all these papers
you guys but it looks like a lot but
it's really not because I just had
because Tom was like holy [__] like look
at all his pages I was like dude it was
just like I just need to like refer to
things
but yeah I should have known like not to
bring up that male female thing oh one
thing that I did want to get into like
real quick and I think I brought this up
earlier was that uh there's this paper
here this the guy that I was talking
about earlier that was kind of like the
um the main Authority I guess like on
Savant His Name Was Daryl uh treffert he
died a couple years ago I think in 2020.
but he did like there's a TED Talk of
his on uh YouTube and like some other
stuff and uh he's actually like really
interesting
um and he has a lot of case studies of
these but he actually him and another
guy like they wrote a paper about what I
mentioned before which was like Sudden
Savant which is kind of the same thing
as acquired Savant but these people
apparently did not have any uh
associated
head injury because normally it'd be
like oh you know I hit my head on the
bottom of a pool or I got struck by
lightning or something then suddenly I
was a piano virtual virtuoso these
people apparently got savant-like
abilities that were similar
but without any
um instigating injury or so it seemed
like or illness or anything like that
now as I said this paper
the study behind it like I said I don't
think they did like any MRIs or anything
it would say it was largely like
self-reported but it does seem like they
took some pains to make sure these
people weren't just like talking out
their ass or like making it up or
whatever but it's like pretty small
sample size it was only like I think 11
cases like overall and some of the cases
were
temporary like for example there was one
guy who reported like I said this is all
self-reporting they did like some pretty
complex
um uh surveys and things like that that
they filled out and then they followed
up with them and interviewed them and
stuff like that to make sure they
weren't just like pulling stuff out
their ass but like there was
um for example like there was a guy who
had been uh stationed in Germany he was
in the army
and he didn't really speak any German uh
or so he thought like he was just kind
of uh he knew a couple of phrases you
know where's the bathroom [__] like that
um but he'd been there for a while like
he'd been there for 18 months two years
something like that so he reported that
he uh was just kind of struggling with
German all the time you know he didn't
really like learn it or anything to any
great degree but he said that he was
talking to a German guy one night and
the German guy like happened to mention
he said his German was so bad that
um that people would be like hey you
know we speak English too it's like why
don't you just speak English it's like
they were tired of like listening to him
struggling right so the fact that
he was at this I think he was like at a
bar one night and he's like he was
talking to a German guy and the German
guy he said suddenly just said something
to him it's like like how long have you
been here because I guess he was saying
it's like you know I don't speak German
very well or whatever and the guy was
like well how long have you been here
he's like oh I've been here for like 18
months and he's like the guy looked at
him and he's like very definitively said
if you've been here 18 months you can
speak German
and he said for a second like it like a
light went on in his head and he said he
had a whole conversation with that guy
like suddenly he could understand like
everything that the guy was saying in
German and he could reply like uh
fluently and [__] like that but
um just the fact that that guy just said
it to him so definitively he's like oh
you're right I can't speak German
because like I said he'd been there a
while so I guess he'd been listening to
it but he said that the effect was only
temporary like it only lasted like a day
or two after that and then like he
couldn't really do it anymore but I kind
of feel like that was sort of
the the gist of like the 11 cases that
they were talking about like in these
Sudden Savant kind of things where these
people didn't
sometimes all it took like as a trigger
was like somebody saying oh you can do
that or you know just realizing that
they could do something or realizing as
I said like the underlying principle
underneath something that was another
thing that was pretty common
that you know people that were never
very good at math for example or
something like that would suddenly just
a light bulb would come out come on and
they would understand like all of the
underlying Concepts uh behind it and
then they would suddenly like understand
all of it like in one big but I kind of
feel like I don't know if that's
necessarily just like a miraculous boom
moment or if it was just kind of like
you know all this stuff but you just
kind of needed that one Catalyst to sort
of
tie it all together or to like give you
the confidence that you actually do know
it
you know because I kind of feel like
there's a there's an element of
confidence behind uh behind something
behind performance and in specific areas
because I mean I was thinking about him
it's weird because I was thinking about
it before we started the show because
you know I read like several papers
about this I watched like some
documentaries and stuff like that but
always no matter what the topic of the
show is I'm always nervous like before
we start it's like I don't know my [__]
I'm just gonna like sit there and I'm
not gonna know anything and I'm just
gonna sit there like drooling and like
not being able to say anything and I
forget everything
but before this show
I kind of thought to myself maybe I
should take a cue from like some of
these people and just be like I know
this [__] you know what I mean and I
don't know if it worked or not I kind of
feel like it was just the same as every
other show but because I'm still like
worried about it but I was like I do
kind of feel like there is an element of
you know I got this [__] or I know what
I'm talking about or something like that
because I kind of feel like
yeah you need to do all the work you
need to study and [__] like that you
can't just pull stuff out of your ass
but
you know self-doubt does kind of like
get in the way of a lot of things so
maybe that was the case with these
Sudden Savant syndrome things but the
the fact that like I said it's a very
small sample size it's only 11 cases
that they're talking about this
particular paper and it's all it's free
online like if you can uh find it uh
Daryl treffert is the guy's name
it's called the Sudden Savant and um I
just found it it's a PDF and the fact
that if these cases are accurate the way
they're reported that's kind of
interesting because that means that you
don't necessarily need to have any kind
of traumatic brain injury you don't
necessarily have to take any kind of
mind-altering drugs you don't
necessarily have to get
electromagnetic pulses like into your
brain or anything like that maybe all it
takes is just like a simple trigger
because like I said to unlock all of
that knowledge which is fascinating to
me because there's like there might be
all kind of cool [__] like lurking
around your brain and all you need to
know how to do is get it out of there
you know I think that's what fascinates
me the most about this kind of
this kind of thing you know yeah well
like you said self-doubt cutting off
abilities hell yeah
yeah confidence is
confidence is the Wellspring of [__]
high performance seen it personally
if you're sitting around [__] I don't
know if I can do a negative mindset no
you're already defeated
Jeffy art said maybe that's how anxiety
functions your brain becomes so
overwhelmed that it'll short-circuit
your ability to process yeah I've
experienced that myself so I do think
that that's uh that's probably how that
works I mean the thing about is that
everything your brain does no matter how
maladaptive it might seem
um probably adapted at some point for
some reason either that or it's a side
effect of some other useful thing
but the thing about it is that our
brains evolved in a very different
environment than what we live in now
so a lot of the things that
you know our brains are used to doing or
the way that our brains work don't
really work as well because you know
obviously culture and Society like moves
a lot faster than Evolution does so you
know we're still
we still have stupid caveman brains and
win like this you know this high-tech
kind of uh Society so there's bound to
be some
problems with that clearly but I don't
know I just I'd find this whole kind of
thing fascinating so much so that when I
was I I almost like when I was driving
home and listening to this podcast I was
like maybe I should go back to school
and be a neuroscientist
that you know what I mean don't laugh at
me okay
what you don't think I could do that no
you could but it's kind of late huh how
long would it take eight years
so okay I could live another [__] 30
or 40 years all right that's a [__]
a lot of bills
I know but it will it's like I don't
know if I would do it or not but it's
like I
don't think it sounds kind of
interesting just well I don't I don't I
don't think of things in terms of that
oh well yeah then didn't just learn it
for free online it probably has some
online courses you can take turns as not
thinking about it is a very useful
technique not that it applies to
everything yeah I I'm not a big fan of
just being like Oh don't think about
stuff because I think you absolutely
should because I think like people just
blunder through the world like idiots
and that's not good either but it's like
in some situations I think sometimes
thinking about stuff too much like you
get in your own way I've seen some dudes
that just had General talent and
confidence do do one-offs that were just
[__] amazing like the dude that was
[__] born to do it and it you know
what I mean just
amazing physical Feats and it was just
like one off and it was the first time
he did it but it looked like it looked
like he did that [__] his whole life
just because confidence confidence and
you know good mind-body connection
coordination and
the thing about it too is that it's not
just I mean you like I said you can't
just be like a total [__] that doesn't
know how to do anything and it's like oh
I can do anything and you know just
suddenly you can't do that like I kind
of feel like
confidence and ability yeah are another
thing that are kind of like an endless
feedback loop yeah like the better you
get at something the more confident
you're gonna be the more confident
you're you are like the better you're
gonna be at it and you're gonna like get
more flow I don't think you can just go
and be well unless you're a
extraordinary individual like you don't
know [__] about [__] no you can't hear
the basics yeah you have to like at
least kind of have a framework or the
basics that you're doing hands-on
experience and familiarization with the
tools that you're going to need to use
but then just you know I've seen dudes
do [__] amazing [__] things in the
Army [__] it was just like God damn
look like something out of a movie and
it was the first time a dude did it
you know yeah well like I said there is
something to be said for not so much
just being
um confident without any basis behind it
but not doubting yourself or not
doubting your abilities you're right you
know yeah I can see that because
sometimes like I said overthinking and I
do it too
you know sometimes you get in your own
way and it kind of like um impedes
your uh your confidence and your ability
and sometimes it makes you get worse at
[__] because you're thinking about it
too much or you're thinking about
failure too much like you think about
the possibilities but you know what I
mean
um all right so I guess it's almost 10
o'clock and I really have to go to bed
soon yeah and I gotta cook I gotta
finish the Carnitas because I have to
get up at five in the morning and it's
you know getting really really late but
hopefully you guys found the show
interesting like I said I found this
topic very very interesting and I don't
remember who it was that
recommended it I'm pretty sure somebody
did but whoever did
um thank you because this was actually a
really interesting show to do maybe
somebody brought it up like when we were
doing the autism show I kind of feel
like because it wasn't that long ago
but yeah um I got really into this and
uh there's a lot of papers online that
you can read for free it's not a huge
amount of TED Talks or YouTube videos
about it but there are some there's a
couple good podcasts on there um that
are interesting to watch if you would
like to but uh yeah so thanks everybody
for dropping by this evening and we will
be back on Friday night for the side
track show as usual have some drinks and
talk about just whatever comes up which
is always kind of fun
so hopefully you guys can join us for
that and hopefully you guys have a good
rest of your evening and we will see you
guys again on Friday
good night
all right